We're here today celebrating the EU's great role
in preventative diplomacy.
What an absolute joke
when the truth is that the EU has been seriously active,
not in preventative diplomacy,
but in preventing diplomacy.
We've had two years,
for the very concept of diplomacy
has been smeared as a Russian plot.
You've pulled out all of the stops
to smash the slightest chance of dialogue in Ukraine.
Where was the preventative diplomacy in 2020 and 2021
when at least France and Germany tried to reduce
the tensions with Russia?
But the EU flung itself behind the US
and NATO belligerence.
And it's the poor people of Ukraine
with its smashed state
that is living with the consequences of that.
Meanwhile, 101 days into the genocide in Gaza
and the EU hasn't even managed to call for a ceasefire.
While this report has the audacity to claim that the EU
always seeks to reduce the risk of escalation.
No, it doesn't.
You're fool and nobody.
It's time to abandon rampant militarism
and stop hurtling down the wrong road of history.